I guess the way that I looked at it is
she's got the fame she doesn't even want
she's not into it she hates the camera
she hates the the interviews the the
circus part of the show but she's got
all the money she's got the record she's
got the two belts another baby on the
way she's got the houses the cars the
like for what like why do you keep going
because like I got a lot of cool
but I don't have the records I'm not a
multi-millionaire like she is I don't I
don't have the belt so like I'm still
chasing that so I'm still like in the
fire what's the reason for her to
continue to go I say I I look forward to
seeing how happy she's gonna be and
people are like wow you're looking for
you know her demise yeah but then she
retires and she's in the Octagon running
around in circles never seen another kid
porn never pouring beer over her head
never and I think that validated your
point he was like yeah look how happy
she is this is exactly what Amanda Nunes
wants to do she owes you guys nothing
hands down no argument the greatest
female fighter of all time it's over
guys if this is how you want their movie
to end man